-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out
with Fred Armisen.
"Los Espookys" tomorrow night.
HBO, HBO Max.
You're not only just
a talented comedian,
you're also
a very talented musician.
And every time you're here,
we ask you to do
a new musical impression for us.
So, this time you brought us
some drum impressions.
-Yes.
-I've never seen these before,
but we have a drum kit ready for
you whenever you're ready.
-Great.
-Go for it.
Thank you, Fred Armisen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, so, the first
impression I'm going to do
is an Instagram drummer.
Like, for some reason
on my feed, I get these videos
of drummers who like to do
close-ups of their kit.
And there's a lot of, like,
gimmicks and stuff
on their drums.
So, every time -- so,
Instagram's a little bit like...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nice.
-When I was a teenager, I think
like a lot of -- I'm just going
to do, like, drumming
through different ages.
And I think teenagers tend to,
like, lean in on fills instead
of the beat,
like the regular beat.
So I used to play kind of like
barely doing a beat, like...
That was, like,
teenage drumming.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, like, really
struggling with it.
Then in my 20s,
I was in this band,
and we played really frenetic,
fast music.
And I just feel like I was just
out to prove that I could play
quickly with a lot of changes,
like...
That kind of thing.
Like just really, really busy.
That's, like, you know,
in my 20s.
And then in my 30s, less toms,
less fills,
but, like, lots of cymbals
to make up for it, so like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then -- Thanks.
Then in my 40s, no cymbals,
high hat very closed,
and, like, really leaning in
on the kick drum, so like...
This is like 40s.
That's like 40s drumming.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, thanks.
And so now in my 50s --
and this is the truth.
This is, like, the groove
I most like to play.
This is the volume I like.
I'm most comfortable doing this.
[ Laughter ]
And --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks. It's really --
I love that -- I love that feel.
So, I think with that
trajectory, as I, you know, go
into my 60s and 70s,
I think my drumming style
is going to be this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Fred Armisen, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Season two of "Los Espookys"
premieres tomorrow
on HBO and HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with Letitia Wright.
Stick around, everybody.
♪♪